finalmente è arrivato il 2021 e abbiamo
tutti i grandi aspettative per questo
anno allo scoccare della mezzanotte
ognuno di noi ha pensato a tutte quelle
cose che ci aspettiamo che 2000 21 porti
con sé ma anche a quella cosa che
speriamo proprio non si porti dietro
arriva gennaio e con lui esami verifiche
ma anche opportunità che allargare i
propri orizzonti
vi consiglio quindi di concentrarvi
sullo studio di smetterla di perdere
tempo
basta distrazioni basta socia certo una
sbirciatina dell'ovo king no no no io
amo lucas è lasciato le nostre strade si
devono separare è stato meno finché è
durato no vabbè vabbè nome non è khan e
sai cosa faccio adesso mi trucco mi
faccio fatica pubblico una foto di
quelle pazzesche è che chi metterà live
dopo tre secondi con una bella frase
filosofica che indirizzata a lui ma non
troppo cioè della serie io sono qui ma
non divento prendere e poi c'è lui il
proposito più gettonato una voglia
irrefrenabile di tornare in forma
determinazione costanza e volontà
saranno le vostre tre migliori amiche
iniziato anno nuovo e sai che cosa vuol
dire chi è arrivato un momento perfetto
per amare giungo a corpo per arrivare
quest'estate con chi ha così i soci che
educa spiaggia o girare pensare perche
non lo faccio anche io
e allora giù rispondere perché ci vuole
motivazione ripetei come motivazione
attivazione e io so che in questo
momento paray a fondi così profondi che
poi chiave arriverà nella storia e lo
farai con il sorriso col sorriso
perfetto allora se tu sei felice non
avrebbe un mega iniziare tutto daccapo
judo vale maneggio proprio maurizio e no
e daccapo no goal sorriso e sii felice
chiave fino in australia e motivazioni e
mobile è stato un po zitta e ultimo non
per importanza
iniziare a risparmiare mettiamo questi
soldi da parte non ci posso credere
un centesimo già finito i soldi che mi
hanno dato natale proprio ora che volevo
comprare i vestiti di mamma
dimmi tesoro sai l'altro giorno mi ha
abbracciato forte forte
io ti abbraccio sempre forte morte sì ma
mentre gli abbracciavi mai detto una
cosa bellissima ma io ti dico sempre
cose bellissime
si ok ma se ti ricordi bene che proprio
detto quando hai bisogno
ok io ci sono sempre per te e quando
avrai bisogno di soldi basta chiederlo e
no ecco questa parte non me la ricordo
mi vuoi dire che è già finito i soldi
che ti hanno dato a natalie parenti
erano più di 300 euro marina del bar a
risparmiare questa volta non ti posso
aiutare mi dispiace ciao
basta questo a me già iniziato malissimo
cavolo non riusciva a mettermi soldi da
parte non riuscirò a tornare in forma ad
allenarmi con costanza e non riuscivo
nemmeno passare gli esami
ehi tu proprio tu no master acceso la
tena
non ti preoccupare tu non devi avere
fretta di salire sulla montagna buoni ti
i tuoi obiettivi e piano piano scalino
dopo scalino raggiungi fosse così
semplice
comunque vada quest'anno sarà
sicuramente meglio se 2020 ah quasi
dimenticavo tieni iscriviti al canale di
marina e attiva tutte le notifiche
cliccando una campanella i suoi video
super divertenti che aiuteranno a
gestire al meglio l'ansia lo stress
regalando dei tanti sorrisi gli scarichi
campanella tutte le notifiche grazie
coach chiamami pure marina
[Musica]